then he went Donald Trump killed Donald
Trump I love Donald Trump but no more
dropped by the drop boxes are just so
bad no more drop boxes Dickinson
hologic and cephe cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
real Beauty had to give the American
people their voice back by building
something called truth truth sensual
and
a four Obama
amnesty as you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the good some of the world's
greatest cricket players from
[Music]
[Applause]
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come on
downstairs
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
United States thank you very much he was
awarded the bronze star and the combat
infantryman badge for his service we
have to keep our country gay people but
it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
law and auto look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
cycling and signing and the great
General and President Ulysses S Grant
he's done he's really come back a long
way over the last 10 years hasn't he
appreciate it very much Tim Apple when
they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they deliver
they swept and swept in you know that
sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasma in the
failing New York Times by an anonymous
really an anonymous gutless coward I may
ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading
woman's business who teach you should
ever be allowed to teach transgender to
our children while not correct up
yourself
no
parental cassette and we will totally
oppose the Biden administration at this
this Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you you heard them and you know them
well ladies and gentlemen do not adjust
your television it is really 2023 and
for the first time in history a
president is being indicted and will
face criminal charges this is all just
such great news such great news I was
proven even more right than I would have
ever imagined because apparently you
know there is actually igniting my
father so great orange leader maybe I
was wrong maybe prayer does work
great communist level of this is
[Music]
communist level of this is
thank you
communist great orange leader Dear
God
[Music]
forbid Donny boy
God forbid Donnie boy great orange
leader Dear God
forbid Donny boy God forbid Donny boy
[Music]
this is
I think that's about all we need to hear
[Music]
elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
[Music]
what on Earth is going on with Trump
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big
McDonald's
[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
second live stream of the day we're live
on YouTube twitch and Facebook and we're
standing by for a speech if you can call
it that a speech if you can call it that
from the failed former twice impeached
twice indicted twice arrested president
Donald J Trump Donald Trump scheduled to
speak at 8 15 PM Eastern I will bet any
amount of money anybody wants to bet me
that that will not happen the reason I
can tell you this is Trump's motorcade
just left Newark Airport at the stroke
of 8 P.M here on the East Coast it's a
35 minute ride even if they go
significantly faster than the speed
limit
it's going to be at least 25 minutes
before they get to Bedminster and of
course then Trump will need to do
whatever ablutions he would do before a
speech and so my instinct would be it
would be a miracle or as Mike pillow
pronounces it a miracle if uh the speech
starts before 8 45 that's my instinct
but fear not we have cameras on the
ground in New Jersey we have super chats
we have voicemails we're going to be
making some twitch donations to some
unsuspecting political streamers and it
is so great to see all of you here today
I don't even really know where to start
other than I guess we'll give a brief
summary of what happened earlier the
president was indeed indicted and
arrested a second time this took place
in Miami Florida
37 felony counts Trump threw his
attorney entered a plea of not guilty
and did not say anything there are
reports that special prosecutor Jack
Smith stared at Trump the entire time
Trump did not even look at special
prosecutor Jack Smith doesn't matter the
evidence will speak for itself doesn't
matter where Trump looks it's not going
to make a difference at the end of the
day
um and then shortly after leaving the
courthouse Trump went to a Cuban
restaurant where people prayed for him
and screamed things which we're going to
look at
um in a little bit let's let um people
get acclimated and get adjusted here
welcome to everybody who uh is joining
us and there are so many different and
important things to discuss let's start
with a few super chats Bernie says
brother Dave seriously what do you think
it would take for the megapotamians to
ditch prompt at this point I think at
this point they wouldn't ditch him no
matter what they would go down with the
ship even if it met their deaths which I
it won't you know but what I'm saying is
even that wouldn't uh wouldn't dissuade
them
did Trump choose New Jersey because of
Christie's recent CNN performance you
know Eric it's a good question it would
seem natural for Trump to fly from Miami
not even you wouldn't even necessarily
have to fly it's like an hour or 75
minutes from Miami to Mar-A-Lago but
Trump going to Bedminster I don't
actually know the reason
um maybe somebody else does Carrie
Swanson says thank you David from
American who lives in Scotland grateful
for your coverage of this process well
my pleasure Carrie it's great to see you
and uh Paul Edwards
um sending the number 47 as a super chat
it's a very deep inside joke from a
recent stream so I don't know that we
need to even explain it people who are
part of the 47 crew of whatever whatever
that even means at this point will
understand the significance of that if
you're just joining you have missed
nothing as far as the second stream goes
Donald Trump is expected to speak at 8
15. it won't happen I think it'll be 8
45 he's on his way from New York airport
to Bedminster and it is a 35 minute ride
um so I just don't think it's going to
be that soon if you were watching our
earlier stream you may recall that we
had Luke the bee's knees Beasley on the
ground in Miami here was one sort of a
proxy interview that Luke was able to do
where I was sort of feeding questions to
him there are so many interviews that
Luke was able to do with magedonians and
maggots and megapotamians here is just
one just as a reminder there will be
plenty more of this on tomorrow's show
that's for damn sure Luke what's the
scene down there
it is pretty wild I'm here with uh
what's your name Greg Donovan
California I wrote yesterday
awesome and uh you want to describe the
sights and the sounds for the audience
I've never seen anything like this uh
supporters is as far as that I mean I've
been to rallies I've seen but this is
unprecedented with the media here it's
uh this is bigger than I've been to the
Super Bowl the World Cup the Olympics
and the Oscars nothing ever like this
it's a sad day in American history I you
could compare it to the uh assassination
of Lincoln and Kennedy that's how bad it
is because he's gonna get my sentence
and if you realize it is a double
standard they're not in in indicting Joe
Biden when he was vice president he got
has the classified documents Luke can
you ask ladies and gentlemen what
evidence there is against Joe Biden so
far
yeah what evidence against Joe Biden is
there so far well they have a lot of
documents I don't know what documents
they have they do say that Trump has
some documents that are not considered
uh their top secret but I know he's
allowed to classify he did say he I mean
to declassify Luke can you ask this
gentleman when he says they have some
documents of Biden what documents does
who have and what evidence of
criminality is that what documents does
who have and what evidence do you have
to that they won't say anything that
what Biden has I haven't heard anything
but I've heard there's something about
something about invading Iran so how
does he know there's evidence of
criminality if he has no idea what he
has but if anything
how do you know there's evidence of
criminality if you're not even sure what
he might have exactly I don't know I
I know so then why does he want Biden
indicted it's a double standard that's
what I'm thinking I'm just saying why do
I think it's a double standard nobody's
saying if you don't know exactly what
Biden would have done wrong then how do
you know he should also be indicted like
Trump
why why don't they why doesn't the
Department of Justice go after him like
they did Trump and invade his home game
set match okay I think we got it yeah
Jesus all right thank you sir
incredibly powerful stuff as you can see
all right so so Luke was on the ground
for a while and he's gonna send me all
of the material
um he said he's working on on putting it
all together right now so I'm hoping to
get this stuff from him um pretty soon
but as you can see just absolutely wild
wild wild stuff down there and it's it's
hard to know whether we should be
laughing or crying to be totally honest
I mean it really is difficult to know
whether laughing or crying is the right
thing okay
um there's been an adjustment as to the
time that Trump is expected from 8 15 to
8 30 that makes sense they were running
late of course getting back to
Bedminster let's look at some other
super chats Juni says David love you in
the show do you know when the Trump
Georgia case is going to trial there's
not going to be a trial unless Trump is
indicted before you're getting you're
putting the cart before the horse Junie
the first question in the Georgia case
this is a totally separate criminal case
remember that Trump may be arrested
three or four times
uh first we have to see if Trump is
indicted by Fannie Willis and we will
know that sometime between mid-july and
early September so we'll take it one
step at a time Haley from Maryland says
I work in a skiff I get in trouble if I
don't lock a drawer behind a locked door
if there are classified documents in it
I served with reality winner and I would
have been charged like she did if I'd
done one of Trump's actions of course
Haley of course
David sir your live streams of these
Trump events are the only things that
get me to take a break from The Legend
of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
interesting stuff
haven't heard of that game yabbits is
supporting Pence hung 2024. that's an
explosive uh candidacy more more than
dissectomonius
um thanks to benevolent King for gifting
five subscriptions on Twitch oh let me
mention we have a very special coupon
code today it's indicted again you all
know what it means we all know what it
means indicted again is the code I want
to say thank you to Jason sickmeyer who
just signed up at joinpakman.com by the
way I want to mention one thing
we have the possibility today we have a
possibility of having more subscribers
on YouTube today than any day of the
year so far if you guys remember the day
that Don Jr went after me that was March
29th that's the biggest day of the year
so far we had 5100 new YouTube
subscribers on that one day
we have the potential to surpass that
and and the tricky thing is I don't know
exactly where we started the day but I
think that we are relatively close
so if you're watching on YouTube and
you're not currently a subscriber just
something to think about just something
to think about because we may indeed get
to an incredible number that very few
people have even seen before all right
Rudy Giuliani is being interviewed As
Trump makes his way to Bedminster let's
take a listen he went to Versailles I
was I just let out a yell yeah
and then about 15 minutes later he
called me he said you know where I was I
said yeah I know where you were your
side I said you're really upset really
nervous aren't you I started laughing
and then we started talking about golf
I mean he's ready to go he knows what's
at stake
he's fighting this battle for us I know
that sounds corny yeah but you know you
know that I'm I'm that's the truth Eric
you know you have the benefit of really
knowing him well and he likes you a lot
and
you know he's fighting this battle for
all of us so-called deplorables in their
eyes
yeah yeah Mr Mayor I appreciate your
time we'll we'll really stay close thank
you so much exactly great job as always
okay thank you all right let's bring in
professor emeritus from Harvard Law oh
God author of the price of principal
here we go
let's talk a little bit about this
um the the evidence can can let's skip
sitting through another painful quote
analysis from Alan dershowitz we did it
on the earlier stream I don't know that
I need to subject everybody to it today
let's look at a couple of different
things here is a completely deranged
Trump supporter earlier today at the
Miami Courthouse uh his statement really
speaks for itself country the most
innocent man that's ever been in the
White House Donald J Trump the best
president we've ever had 45 47. he's
coming back this is the longest Witch
Hunt going on eight years now since he
came down the escalator you believe the
guy's an American hero do you believe
there's a two-tier system of justice do
you believe this is unfair obviously I
don't even know how anybody can ask that
with a straight face there's obviously a
two-tier justice system why is the
Clinton crime family running wild why is
Beijing Biden and the money laundering
operation that Hunter Biden started out
of uh Ukraine he started the war on
Ukraine five years ago when he was
working for barisma
oh my goodness oh wow I would suggest
decaf last question If by uh Trump were
to get reelected should he consider a
pardon for the Biden family absolutely
not they're a crime family you're either
an American or a Democrat yeah yeah
there's no way to be both there you go
and that is the final point there as you
can uh as you can imagine let's see uh
oh this tweet's been deleted
um he we looked at this one earlier
here's a woman completely losing her
mind unclear whether she is having a
medical event just a radical extremist
she is holding a beer so maybe that's a
factor
but look where they live look where they
Blackline mother people live they have
become rich do you think they care about
Hispanics do you think they care about
Black Americans no they don't they
denigrade us they want us to die
crossing the border
all the political opponents was the
first one to condemn that
he goes around the world preaching about
democracy about honesty with one moral
Authority is doing that when he is doing
exactly what is being done in Nicaragua
by this folks when I held the beer once
I got arrested so the fact that this
woman held a beer could could mean
anything
in this country there's no separation of
powers they are not treating Republicans
the way that they treat the Democrats if
we protest for what they're doing to the
children they call us terrorists they
think we are the war terrorists and we
are passionate because I lost one nation
once and I'm not gonna lose a second one
I love the United States of America
immigrants immigrants Exiles from all
over the world that have suffered love
the United States my guess certainly
would be that this is a human Cuban
woman from her accent and as many of you
know the Cuban people in their
absolutely warranted and Justified
rejection of the Castro regime
have unfortunately some have fallen for
some really wacky American right-wing
stuff and I don't know how many of these
Cuban right-wingers are familiar with
the most famous cuban-american streamer
in the world Stephen Kenneth Destiny
benell Goranson II
um but I would love for them to appear
with him I think that that would be a
really great thing speaking of the Cuban
American Community Donald Trump made a
stop at a Cuban restaurant and uh things
went a little bit Haywire
[Applause]
I guess it's Trump's birthday tomorrow
and then um then they did prayer and it
looks like there's I don't even want to
say a rabbi there's a guy with a yamaka
right I don't know that that's a rabbi
but I guess these are Faith leaders
praying for Trump I don't know if
they're praying for Trump or if they're
praying over Trump
that is Hebrew that's Hebrew with a
Hispanic with a Spanish accent that's
fascinating that's that brings back
that's nostalgic for me
and now we've switched to Spanish
he's saying give him strength in his
hands
and in his body
[Music]
very very uh you you know that was very
meaningful for Trump because Trump is
deeply spiritual as many of you know and
then Trump announcing free food for
everyone are you ready are you ready
food for everyone
I would get a credit card in advance if
I was the restaurant
[Applause]
wow
um powerful imagery extremely extremely
powerful imagery as you all uh certainly
certainly now the world is laughing at
us the world is crying and the world is
laughing at us I want to say thank you
to Juan the troll man Eric Joslin Carrie
Kurtz Ryan Dempsey David Levin and Grant
Ritchie who all just signed up on my
website folks come on in we have a
coupon code indicted again I would love
for you to support the work that we are
all doing here to bring you the podcast
multiple streams everything go to
joinpakman.com sign up it's quick and
easy and also please make sure you hit
that subscribe button on YouTube I think
we're probably about 1200. my sense is
if we get to 1.74 million tonight today
will be the record for new subscribers
uh in a single day this year that that's
my that's my sense of the situation
Donald Trump scheduled to speak five
minutes ago then adjusted to 10 minutes
from now I don't think we'll hear from
Trump until 8 45 to be perfectly honest
I think that that's more or less the way
it's going to go Clockwork Shadow says
always a joy listening to your streams
Pac-Man here's to seeing Trump behind
prison bars soon Marshall says do you
think Trump capitalizes random words
because he thinks it makes his truths
look like America's founding documents
kind of ties in well with his delusions
of grandeur I don't know why Trump
capitalizes random words I really don't
know
K Bragg says the aliens for sure ain't
never going to talk to us after this
Fair
Ali Reza saying I am saying it on behalf
you if praying did not work for students
in Nashville it is not going to work for
Trump either
Tommy says happy indicated day
photo says is it really free food he'll
just pay for lunch from their campaign
donations more than likely yeah there's
always some scam with Trump uh all right
guys let's do this again I have re-upped
my bits and we now have bits ready to
donate to random small streamers we're
gonna try some political streamers okay
let's try donating to some political
streamers with very few views and seeing
what is up with them how about uh oh I
don't know how about let's see who this
is
Syndicate one has one viewer let's see
what's up here
we now want to discuss these numbers is
David Wessel he's director of the
locations Center let's get away from
that they seems dollars they seem just
to be playing Clips let's see who's
actually on screen how about this guy
let's see what's up with this guy I'm
the person that got Epstein's Island
closed
uh actually I'm having a sort of second
thoughts about that let's see uh what's
up with this guy here some uh you know
various information looking at new
stories yeah the searching through uh
this seems like right wing nuttery so I
don't want to donate to that man this is
genuinely tough to find reasonable
things how about Chad Mary
preparing
let's try this one
let's dump in a little donation here
okay let's go to bits and then let's do
how about 20 bucks
keep up the great work all right let's
see what is going on with this
particular person
here we go
and obviously air surveillance in order
to see where the ukrainians are coming
from making it very difficult for the
ukrainians to get through all the layers
of these defenses without getting stuck
which makes it very challenging for the
Ukrainian side especially because it's
non-plexed right now at the 20 bucks
thank you so much
oh
hello
guys
uh David Pacman
and Lagos and
Yara
yarash
garu sorry
hello
where are you from guys do they know I
donated 20 bucks uh thanks for
follows
I was just about to ask Lenny if if if
if you're dying there
with this orange sky or not hmm
oh my God what's going on
where are you coming from guys
thanks for your follow can I get a
refund
listen guys I'm trying super nice to see
you
all right because she didn't notice I
sent 20 bucks all right let's
let's try one more
let's see
if we can find one more
uh someone with very few
viewers but do oh how about this young
black economist
let's check this one out and see what's
up
where you came from kind of idea I'm
like no we stay here you go back all
right let's give it a shot you give the
land back to the Native Americans I'll
live under their Rule and we'll be good
okay thanks for having me good like that
would be that's what that's what you
know you go back right so like the idea
that we should leave I think is
[Music]
it doesn't make sense like to say that
um thank you for the bits oh thank you
thank you so much a lot thank you
um uh thanks for having me okay thank
you for coming in um they're not the
real David Pacman are you yes I am weird
um whoever you are thank you for
stopping stopping in I'm the real
difference um and also uh nice prep
thank you also for coming in no um and
then let's see uh no no it's pretty
convincingly yeah please please don't
you can do there's no real
data uh that suggests they make a
difference
it really is David oh if it really is
David how how are you it's nice to meet
you doing well thank you
foreign
yes I had a video of yours actually that
I was going to play earlier um the one
you did of if that is a real one the one
that he put up of like the Trump one
maybe we'll play that in a bit let's see
um but I saw that this morning is on my
list I was actually thinking I was like
I could play this right all right well
thank you very much everybody uh doing a
little bit of donation there hope
everybody enjoyed that found some actual
political streamers which I think is
really really great okay so we did it
um all right let's continue we are
awaiting Donald Trump any moment now
expected to arrive I think he will
arrive at Bedminster in the next seven
to ten minutes
um and then uh probably speak around 8
45 that's my guess let's see what Carrie
lake has to say about all of this she
knows about telling the truth doesn't
she left would help didn't play it out
and is actually playing out
well thank you for having me Eric and
you're right this has never happened
before we've never had somebody as
corrupt as Joe Biden sitting in the
White House somebody who would dare to
take our government and weaponize it
against his rival the uh the front
runner in the next political
presidential race and he's so afraid Joe
Biden is because the truth is starting
to unfold about him what he's been up to
what his criminal family has Trump is
involved in unprecedented presidential
wrongdoing and they're talking about Joe
Biden it's these people are parodies of
themselves allowing the fake news media
to go after that and cover it he's
throwing this detour and pushing these
bogus charges against President Trump I
was in Miami today I was blown away by
the level of support and pure there were
reportedly a few hundred people there
maybe a thousand based on media reports
much they had filled they were wearing
their Trump shirts their Trump hats what
craving Flags the people love president
Trump he's a man of the people and we
know a bogus fake phony Witch Hunt when
we see it yes completely fake phony
witch hunts
carried out at completely different
levels of the justice system state and
federal carried out by completely
unrelated investigators and prosecutors
who have nothing to do with each other
there don't you understand guys the
entire New York Alvin Bragg thing is a
Witch Hunt and also the entire
Washington DC Jack Smith investigation
is a Witch Hunt and also the completely
unrelated Georgia investigation by
fonnie Willis is also a Witch Hunt and
it is all being orchestrated by Joe
Biden at a certain point you have to
just apply some colloquial version of
Occam's razor and say maybe Trump
actually has habits of doing things
incorrectly maybe he doesn't care about
the law at some point you've got to ask
the question Haley says LOL except Trump
weaponized his Government after his
Rivals oh the projection is blistering
blistering why wouldn't the magats be
rioting if they think this is corruption
maybe they've been lying yeah who knows
what the maggots actually think at any
particular point in time it's
essentially impossible to know they
they're in a complete and total fantasy
world uh of of their own of their own
creation let's listen to a little bit of
what's going on on right side
broadcasting we got the Trump training
card love that Birch gold love them the
wellness company loved them but we also
have our viewer who we love more than
anything so go to our web all right so
there's Marjorie Taylor Green's
boyfriend talking about things
um CBS News is uh covering what took
place earlier here is Fox News now let's
listen
before the 13th amendment was ratified
and all enslaved people in America were
declared free
America is a promise
a promise of freedom
liberty and justice
the story of Juneteenth as we celebrate
it is the story of our own very
important and we will be following up
about Juneteenth in fact by the way we
are going to be off for Juneteenth it's
something we have never done at the
David Pacman show before but we are now
uh we are taking it seriously as a
holiday and we are going to be off in
part it's also because I will be um
traveling to a wedding so that's going
to be
realistically also a factor I I do have
to admit that Tristan says this just
then Trump demands answers as to the
oranges of the indictment I would want
to see the oranges as well let's listen
to a few voicemails that have been
coming in about this stream
Hey sir uh did you see that Kevin's pit
um supported Ron DeSantis and Trump went
bananas yeah for people who don't know
the Governor of Oklahoma Kevin's tit
announced that he would be supporting
Ron de sanctimonious and a trump flipped
out saying not only did the Sanctus only
win thanks to Trump tit also only won
thanks to Trump so it's it's it's truly
a mess it's truly a mess
uh let's see what else we've got hey
David I can't help but notice that
you're um
wearing glasses now
um just thought I'd bring that up that
is true I am currently I am currently
wearing glasses that is absolutely the
case
hey David it's Tommy um you know
everybody is talking about this
indictment but
you know
maybe it's just a distraction because
what we should all really be talking
about is Obama gate I recommend me with
you don't know what Obama gate is
everybody knows what it is and it's the
crime of the century
and this is just a political Witch Hunt
I I agree this is all really a cover-up
for Obama gate which we still don't know
what it is but
um I'm sure we will someday we will
someday find out I think that that's
probably
probably the case
Trump's arraignment
I thought to myself
how has this country changed this much
in just my lifetime I was born the day
before President Nixon gave his
resignation speech wow
how since that date
have we now come to where despite the
fact that our president is
kind of caught red-handed
he's still saying he's not guilty oh
Trump's not going to ever admit to
wrongdoing Trump's never apologized for
anything in his life not going to start
now
Uh Kevin K Bragg brings up a good uh
point the guy who needs cue cards to
remember his name is The Mastermind
behind this massive conspiracy yeah you
know I I can't figure out
is Biden completely senile and an
invalid and doing nothing or has he
found a way to Mastermind multiple
unrelated indictments against Donald
Trump and is controlling everything like
which which is it exactly please tell me
which of the two it is
uh let's see what else do we have hey
Dave I know this is a repetitive
voicemail but maybe you'll catch it on
live
explain to me how it is not biased
and political
for your party to insist what party I'm
not a Democrat what's what party is this
guy talking about I don't care about the
Democratic party that only a democratic
judge should oversee the arraignment
I haven't heard anybody saying that
I don't think anyone has a problem
with a so-called Republican judge
overseeing the arraignment I think the
issue is that it's a trump appointed
person
this call is off the rails okay I'm
going to move on because it's just so so
bonkers
uh okay
how do they explain the fact that Trump
who took out the sitting doj in his
presidency with a new hand-picked Trump
director of the doj was weaponized by
Joe Biden not sure I totally understand
but none of what they're saying makes
sense
friendly reminder if you see ads for
Trump currency online flag it as a scam
uh let's see what else we have gas man
says love your work David my friend ran
into you at a coffee shop a few weeks
ago had a conversation with you about
your appearance on the Lex Friedman show
bombed I wasn't with him keep oh yeah
your friend said if my friend knew I ran
into you
my friend would be going nuts right now
so well listen this happens this happens
uh I was having a cortado you know I
have to admit I have been starting the
transition off of the cappuccino
over to the cortado at least as far as
afternoons are concerned I prefer less
milk it's not a lactose intolerance
thing or anything like that it's just
it's just where I'm going at this point
in time I've been going uh in the
direction of the cortado less milk folks
less milk please people asking what it
is
Charlie says David I haven't heard bag
of mangoes in ages was it pulled When
Diamond passed away no and bag of
mangoes will be on the Spotify album
coming up very soon
did Luke Beasley make it out okay yes he
did he made it out of Miami just fine he
made it out of Miami just fine
will his team have prepared this
evening's rant or is Trump going
entirely off the cuff or a mix I presume
it will be a mix there is a prompter up
as you can see so there will at least
theoretically be a teleprompter for
Trump if Trump was DNA tested what are
the odds it will match some unsolved
crimes oh I don't I don't know I don't
even want to get into that that's that's
a scary that's a scary question welcome
to Byron Taylor and Desiree Delong both
using the coupon code indicted again
ladies and gentlemen you have the
opportunity today to sign up on my
website with the heretofore unannounced
coupon code
indicted again
simply and folks the right under I hate
to say this the right understands this
the right understands that the way they
win is by actually funding a media
ecosystem
you go to joinpakman.com the coupon code
indicted again and it just crumbles the
price down to pennies so low neither
Rudy Giuliani nor Alan dershowitz want
me to say it out loud because it is just
so crazy it is just so crazy thanks also
to Jason sickmeyer for gifting another
membership if you want a free membership
listen carefully please
if you want a free membership
go to davidpackman.com free membership
do not email me the email will be
deleted
okay if you want a free membership one
of these that's being gifted go to
davidpackman.com free membership it's
super simple super super super simple
stuff and thanks to Fang duster and Goth
geek for the uh twitch Prime
subscriptions let's listen to actually
let's do a couple more Super chats Trump
will be speaking soon he's just arrived
our other candidates on Truth Central
How Will trump handle them campaigning
on his Turf I have no idea who's on
truth
couldn't couldn't tell you
do I think on some level this is
politically motivated of course that's
probably why it's a good idea that if
you have enemies and haters don't do
illegal shh
powerful message
thank you for all your effort with all
this coverage says Phoenix Matthias
you're a gentleman and a scholar David
well thank you very much thank you very
much we are standing by moments away
from Trump
um voicemails keep pouring it I have a
request for you and your show so just
pretend Lee or and Deli the two Shaman
we all know who he is why does this
caller sound like he's underwater from
prison and apparently has a profile on
Backstage website speaking work as an
actor I don't even want to get into that
it's not I just I don't even want to get
into that hey David Oley from Dallas
um remember when uh former president and
now criminal defendant Trump uh altered
a Weber map I think this was back in
2019 yeah now
I honestly believe that you know Joe
Biden and I mean I don't think he would
ever do this but if he ever altered a
weather map
you know he would be impeached on the
spot
um but yeah I thought that
you know that was a crazy time and yeah
it's there have been so many of these
insane things that it's actually hard to
remember all of them it's it's really
really wild there is a helicopter as I
predicted Trump expected to speak more
like 8 45 now Trump is at Bedminster and
will be speaking momentarily thank you
to Texas bear claw for the twitch Prime
subscription there's no better thing to
do than to take a few bucks from Jeff
Bezos and send them our way I also want
to say thank you to Mark Marquette who
just signed up at joinpakman.com using
the coupon code indicted again which is
an insane coupon code uh and I am a
little worried that the website is going
to collapse because so many people are
trying to sign up right now but we're
gonna we're gonna work on keeping the
website up as strongly absolutely as
strongly as we can
um okay let's take a listen see what's
being said uh pled not guilty in all uh
counts and uh was released uh basically
with limited travel are limited
restrictions and in terms of no
restrictions on travel
um and he could not talk to any of the
um Witnesses other defendants in the
case and Witnesses
that was I'm just kind of going over
some notes here just make sure some
programming notes also here uh okay
a big big big thank you to Nissa Hartman
Mike Roberts Alan Greenfield Brian pajak
and Emily Salter signing up at
joinpakman.com I will advise people the
website is hanging by a thread and we
may genuinely run out of memberships
which which would just be insane people
don't talk about it but the tanker crash
that took out I-95 was suspiciously
close to Four Seasons total Landscaping
coincidence I will look into that I will
look into that I have a video I took of
a fox host pronouncing truth social as
truth social all tweeted at you all
right
thanks okay we read this one already
very very good
um folks you you haven't missed the
speech yet Trump is about to speak he
just recently arrived at Bedminster and
he is about to speak uh momentarily we
have a couple other voicemails coming in
David sir very strong stream I must say
thank you live stream is there any way
that we can make the
Republican voters realize that the party
that they have been voting for
is actually the opposite of what they
claim to be
because they're not pro-life actually
they're not for family they're not Law
and Order they you know they're not
they're definitely not personal
responsibility listen here's my answer
whenever people ask me this type of
thing and Donald Trump has now just
arrived alongside here where he will be
speaking
uh of course there is a way
to convince these people listen cult
members are sometimes deprogrammed
so of course there is a way
the Practical question that I have for
you is is it easier to deprogram
cultists
or find people who already agree with us
and and just convince them to vote
I believe that the latter is easier and
that's why I believe that is a better
strategy for winning
as a just sort of like you know you want
to try to convince some people by all
means it can be done but it I don't
believe that it is a strategy
Palisade try igamer and I cannot stop
twinkling have just re-upped twitch
Prime subscriptions which I really
appreciate it is being pointed out that
Melania has been missing for a while I
don't really care about this but I
people keep asking about it so I
researched it a little bit the reports
are that after Trump was found liable
for sexual assault
um Melania essentially Rena tried to
renegotiate their financial Arrangement
and the reporting is Trump gave her a
bunch of money not to more formally
separate but that they basically live
completely separate lives she made a
very milk toast public statement about
how she supports Trump's run but that
essentially it is you know sort of like
they have an arrangement and it involves
money
and that's that's the story with it
folks uh we are experiencing massive
membership dumps on the website I want
to thank Jennifer netherley Jason
greathouse Scott Vetter Denny Morissette
Caroline Jones Erica Davis Douglas
Maloney Sparrow suleimane there is Eric
Trump uh Denise Spears Alana Adams Bry
Kelly or Bree Kelly and Nicholas Dodson
putting us at 46 the coupon code is
indicted again and if you're not
currently in a position to subscribe I
have free memberships available at
davidpackman.com free membership if you
type it plural it won't work it's
singular davidpackman.com free
membership and I would invite you to
make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel we are very close to
making today the top Day on YouTube of
the Year surpassing March 29th the the
day that Don Jr hacked me that was
that's the next best uh that's the next
best day
so it's all happening it's all happening
and Trump will be speaking momentarily
Eric Trump has just arrived and we
continue to receive more and more
voicemails hi David this is Devin from
Easton Pennsylvania yes it's been
bothering me how Trump's documents case
ended up with judge Cannon I find the
possibility to be all right here he is
we will get back to that here he comes
here he comes here he is President Trump
45. take a listen
[Applause]
[Music]
my prediction folks is that this speech
will contain a bunch of the normal stuff
Trump will talk about maybe he'll tell
the Abdul story or the weightlifting
story or any of those but that it I
believe it's going to be particularly
unhinged big thank you to Terry long
Danielle Stewart Sarah officer Bill
Dickhouse Isaac reisborg and Julie Clark
really appreciate everybody who's
signing up and coming out today it it's
just unbelievable Hector arizola is our
newest member this is the failed former
president twice indicted twice impeached
also a big thank you to bag Smasher Von
Julio white nervosa burnt nacho and
Dicky Seamus all signing up on Twitch
those are some aggressive usernames
let's listen this is Donald Trump's post
arrest speech arrested a second time you
know how Trump says I ran twice I won
twice more like I allegedly committed
crimes twice and they arrested me twice
together
and defend her still today cause there
ain't no doubt and thank you s Prez for
gifting 50 subscriptions on Twitch s
Prez has now gifted
3836 subscriptions on Twitch and maybe
the first person ever to breach four
thousand which is just a stunning
stunning number I expect this speech to
be shorter than most Trump speeches I
don't think this will go a hundred
minutes I don't believe it will be a
castro-like speech but we can only wait
and see
um Eric says his only regret in life is
not getting a membership and accessing
the bonus show sooner that I can
empathize with that I can absolutely
empathize with
[Music]
thank you thank you
cult
well thank you very much thank you it's
great honor to have you here and
today we witnessed the most evil and
heinous abuse of power in the history of
our country we did where corrupt sitting
president had his top
political opponent arrested on fake and
fabricated charges of which he and
numerous other presidents would be
guilty there is no evidence Biden did
anything special election
in which he is losing very badly
Biden is winning most polls
this is called election interference and
yet another attempt to rig and steal a
presidential election
more importantly it's a political
persecution like something straight out
of a fascist or a communist Nation
they will go down and infamy and Joe
Biden will forever be remembered as not
only the most corrupt president of the
history of our country but perhaps even
more importantly
the president who together with a band
of his closest thugs Misfits and
marxists tried to destroy American
democracy could we name the marxists I
still can't find them Ellen we will win
bigger and better than ever before
charging a former president of the
United States under the Espionage Act of
1917 wasn't meant for this an act for a
crime so heinous that only the death
penalty would do and threatening me with
400 years in prison for possessing my
own presidential papers which just about
every other president has done is one of
the most outrageous and vicious legal
theories ever put forward in an American
court of law is it the Espionage Act
has been used to go after Traders and
spies it has nothing to do with a former
president legally keeping his own
documents
as president the law that applies to
this case is not
the Espionage Act but very simply the
presidential records act even uh William
Barr Trump's own former Attorney General
has debunked this failed false notion
under the presidential records act which
is civil not Criminal
I had every right to have these
documents
The crucial legal precedent is laid out
in the most important case ever on the
subject known as the Clinton Sox case
a sock draw you know what that means
after leaving the White House Bill
Clinton kept 79 audio tapes in his sock
draw sock drop included discussions of
U.S military involvement in isn't the
word drawer I've never heard anyone call
it that it's bizarre offense against
Cuba
recordings of President Clinton's
conversations with
all of the many foreign leaders at the
time think of that sensitive facts about
trade negotiations taken from
presidential briefings discussions with
the Secretary of State about conflict in
Bosnia and much much more
very big stuff Not only was Bill Clinton
never even considered for criminal
prosecution based on the tapes he took
but when he was sued for them he won the
case
Judge Amy Berman Jackson's decision
States under the statutory scheme
established by the presidential records
Act
the decision to segregate personal
materials from presidential records is
made by the president during the
president's term
and in the president's Soul discretion
be surprised to hear that aren't you no
any normal Administration even an
opposing one would consider that to be
the end
but not the corrupt Biden Administration
the Sox decision as it's known also
States quote the National Archives and
Records Administration or Nara
does not have the authority to designate
material as presidential records I don't
have the authority
Nara does not have the tapes in question
and narrow lacks any right Duty or means
to seize control of them this is law
the president enjoys unconstrained
authority to make decisions regarding
the disposal of documents that's
unconstrained
to make that decision neither the
archivist nor Congress has the authority
to veto the president's decision
the presidential records act does not
confer any mandatory or even
discretionary Authority
on the archivist to classify records
just so people know
all of this stuff went out the window
when Trump obstructed directed lawyers
to lie refused to turn documents over it
was no longer about the status of the
documents alone this has been widely
debunked by Republicans and Democrats
this is nonsense just so people know
that right to do so it's an absolute
right this is the law
and that is something that people have
now seen and it couldn't be more clear
they ought to dropped this case
immediately because they're destroying
why
and this is why no other president even
those who kept far more documents than I
has ever
been even investigated let alone charged
with a crime
because the Sham indictment put forward
by the Biden Administration included
stage photographs of boxes at Mar-A-Lago
many people have asked me why
I had these boxes why did you want them
the answer in addition to having every
right under the presidential records Act
is that these boxes were
containing all types of personal
belongings many many things shirts and
shoes and everything
as can be seen in the picture where
someone not me
I wonder who it might have been
dumped one of the very neatly arranged
boxes all over the floor
they were full of newspapers press
flippings thousands of pictures
thousands and thousands of White House
pictures
the White House photographers some are
with us today they took so many pictures
and we saved all of them and they were
in those boxes
clothing memorabilia and much much more
I hadn't had a chance to go through all
the boxes it's a long tedious job takes
a long time
which I was prepared to do but I have a
very busy life I've had a very busy life
they make it more busy because you're
always fighting right
it's everyone else's fault and under the
Sox decision
there seemed to be no rush I wasn't in a
rush because that decision was a law
the other picture that was so vile you
remember that one it was angry and
corrupt was the photo staged by the FBI
and those that raided Mar-A-Lago they
were
putting documents all over the floor
remember that famous picture all over
say confidential said presidentials and
all sorts of things and it was supposed
to be there like
it was that way when they raided it
wasn't that way they put them there took
the picture and released it illegally to
the Press
they took my medical records my passport
my birth certificate and apologized
they even brought a safe tractor this is
a professional safe cracker they brought
into Mar-A-Lago safe cracked her they
broke into
found nothing there was nothing there
they spied on my campaign zero
according to the presidential records
act which was a big deal
I was supposed to negotiate with Nara
which is exactly what I was doing until
Mar-A-Lago was rated by gun toting FBI
agents
I have security tapes of it I gave them
security tapes of everything
in a flagrant violation of the Fourth
Amendment of the Constitution which
protects the right there was of course
no violation of the first the fourth
amendment that was we've looked at that
extensively I have to give Trump credit
he's doing new material he's not just
doing his old stories that I mean that's
something you covered very well I must
say
very well I'm not the one who thinks I'm
above the law I'm the one that followed
the law I'm the only one we will see
it's Joe Biden and his corrupt
Department of Injustice who think they
are above the law
never before have the two standards of
Justice in our country been more starkly
revealed
Joe Biden had troves of classified
documents from his time as vice
president and even as a senator
which was completely and totally illegal
in fact other Senators heard about it
Dick Durbin heard about it you have to
see his response there's no way that's
totally illegal took him as a senator
out of a skiff
they were shocked when they found out
they actually thought it was impossible
to do
Biden sent
1850 boxes
to the University of Delaware making the
search very very difficult for anybody
and he refuses to give them up and he
refuses to let people even look at them
and then they say how he's behaving so
nicely
many of Biden's classified documents
were you guys noticing Trump's doing a
really weird breathing thing we're at
the end of a sentence
he kind of makes a weird face and does
an in-breath with a sneer how many times
the
friends of ours from China review those
documents Chinatown DC
others were unsecured at his so-called
Penn Biden Center in Washington which
paid Biden approximately one million
dollars a year the money supposedly
coming from China and still other
classified documents were strewn
all over his garage floor were his now
famous Corvette is stored he's so proud
of that car
there was no security and the door was
left open
most of the time it was open all of
those classified documents all of those
documents strewn all over the floor
piled up like junk
unlike me who had absolute
declassification Authority as president
Joe Biden as vice president had no
authority to declassify and no right to
possess
the documents he had no right instead of
falling under the presidential records
Act Biden's actions fell under a much
stricter Federal records act which has
very very tough
criminal penalties yet nothing happens
to Crooked Joe nothing happened have you
heard anything about the big search for
his documents no only me he turned him
over most and famously of all Hillary
Clinton set up
an illegal private server in her
basement you never heard this story
with it Hillary Clinton was careless but
was investigated and did not appear to
have committed any crime she also
cooperated with the investigation the
Clinton foundations or whatever
Hillary is to advance quantities of
classified and sensitive information on
her illicit server
some of it happened to Lake it leaked
into Anthony Weiner's computer remember
Anthony winter
into his computer you don't want to be
on his computer
and all of it was illegal
because thankfully
she was never president she didn't have
the powers to declassify
field
Obama she didn't have the powers to
declassify it's a big difference and
neither did Joe you know Joe didn't have
your mind have a drink
here we go oh boy
it's a little bit cooler than it was but
it's pretty hot out here
thank you happy birthday happy birthday
great birthday
tomorrow is Trump's birthday I believe
nice birthday isn't it yeah tomorrow
and we will ban men
nice birthday
wonderful birthday
they're saying happy birthday I was with
I was with Eric and Laura the kids happy
birthday grandpa happy and I said oh
great I just got charged with they won
400 years approximity
pull up a fake a fake 400 years though
thank you darling that's so nice he is
worried it's a wonderful birthday
we're gonna make it into the greatest
birthday of all
[Applause]
then deleted an acid wash Nobody Does
that because of the expense but it's
pretty conclusive she bleached It 33 000
emails in defiance of a congressional
subpoena I heard that she actually
cleaned him he was there and she decided
to delete acid wash and then Smash and
Destroy her cell phones with a hammer
and then they say I participated in
obstruction
now think of it that's called
she reportedly took a tide stick to a
USB drive is that she did this in the
face of everything and yet
nobody did anything about it
the FBI and the doj protected her did
not issue subpoenas did not use a grand
jury it did not execute search warrants
and then the
corrupt head of the FBI James Comey
declared no reasonable prosecutor would
bring a case can you believe it
[Music]
[Applause]
and that was just one of many items
Hillary Clinton broke the law
and she didn't get indicted not with law
enforcement Joe Biden broke the law and
in many other ways we're finding out
and so far has not gotten indicted I did
everything right and they indicted me
but you know we're serving as a great
example and
the case of Bill Clinton's National
Security advisor remember that Sandy
Berger he was caught stealing classified
documents from the national Army in his
pants big ones very important ones by
stuffing them in his pants
and putting them also in his socks and
he destroyed them and cut
the tape with scissors cut them all up
what Burger did was highly illegal but
he was given
nothing no jail time nothing nothing
happened there are countless other
examples Bill Clinton
who I happen to like hard to believe
right before I did this I was actually
quite friendly with him
nice guy they should have used him a
little bit more as an advisor on the
2016 election he said you know you
better get to Wisconsin you're going to
lose no we're not you better get to
Michigan you're going to lose no we're
not they did sure
Bill Clinton lost the nuclear codes and
absolutely nothing was done about he'd
lost the nuclear codes is this the
laundry bit
the George W bush White House lost
22 million emails a record
Nara cannot issue a complete transfer of
any of the Bush records
a document shredding truck was spotted
on the way to
Dick Cheney's house can you imagine
Hillary Clinton took hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of furniture
China flatware rugs and more from the
White House
and she wasn't prosecuted how about that
when she took the furniture
and the China this is nuts How about if
Trump did that you think Trump would
have a little problem
the horrific violations of my rights by
crooked Joe Biden's weaponized
Department of Injustice are Unthinkable
it's Unthinkable what's happened so bad
for our country
Democrats all
they lawlessly pierced
my attorney-client privilege with
lawyers what they did to lawyers what
they have it's called the crime fraud
exception we've already talked about it
for our lawyers they've done things that
were absolutely horrible and unthinkable
the leaking has been unbelievable and
highly illegal they leak
we've learned more about
from The Washington Post New York Times
about the doj's boxes hoax it's a boxes
hoax then from prosecutors themselves we
want to read about it you pick up the
Washington Post
which is not doing well or you pick up
the New York Times but they'll do better
now because of these things you know
this is the only way they survive but
they'll end up dying
but it's not supposed to be that way we
don't want to learn from the times we
don't want to learn from leaks we want
to learn from the people we're supposed
to learn from it's like a leaking sieve
it doesn't know who they are
but we learned nothing about the Biden
bribery scheme or special counsel Robert
hurd's investigation Robert Herr is
doing the Biden investigation he's a
very respected very nice person
very nice person
mine's not such a nice person mine's a
deranged lunatic
which are many times the magnitude of
ours in both number and severity
that's the prosecutor that they gave he
has found nothing he totally exonerated
Mike Pence I'm happy about that Mike did
nothing wrong but he happened to have
classified documents in his house
but they exonerated him and uh Biden is
a different story man so much you have
to really think about what I said as a
senator he took all of those documents
it's unprecedented
the prosecutor in the case
I will quote our case is a thug I've
named him deranged Jack Smith wow clever
I wonder what his name used to be Jack
Smith it sounds so innocent Dustin Jack
Smith what's his name Jack Smith he's a
very nice man
he's a behind the scenes guy
but his record is absolutely atrocious
he does political hit jobs he's
been known to viciously arrest a certain
Governor you know the governor
Bob McDonald of Virginia and absolutely
ruined his life and the life of his
family all these wonderful let me know
in the chat are you finding this
convincing of Trump's innocence eight to
nothing by the Supreme Court he
destroyed that man and he destroyed that
family
and by the way
I will tell you I'm here and I love you
all you're convinced yeah and we can
take it
but what these thugs what these thugs
have done to my family is a disgrace I
will tell you that I say it to all of
the fake news because there's a lot of
it back then
[Music]
what they did to my family and that
young man right there
he's answered more subpoenas than any
human being in the history of the world
and you know what they have nothing
after all of those subpoenas literally
thousands of them
Congress honestly and I'm not joking
around I would rather Trump explain why
there's a chandelier in his bathroom and
why given that he's so wealthy his
bathroom looks so terrible so my
bathrooms are way nicer than that
Mar-A-Lago bathroom it's crazy money
really can't buy class these are serious
people but what he's done to my family
what they have done to my family is
horrible he also tried to Railroad John
Edwards on a completely bogus legal
theory that didn't hold up in court
it's no wonder this raging lunatic was
shipped off to the Hague to prosecute
war criminals using globalist tribunals
not beholden to the Constitution or the
rule of law two things Jack Smith
clearly disdains you take a look at this
guy he looks like a thug
but then I watched him make a speech the
other then he was trembling because it
wasn't his territory he feels much safer
in the inner sanctums of the
Department of Injustice where he can be
in his room and scream at people
he's a raging and uncontrolled Trump
hater
as is his wife who also happened to be
the producer of that Michelle Obama puff
piece it was total puff piece Obama this
is the guy I've got
don't forget this persecution is being
done by the same weaponized agencies
that for seven years have been running
illegal psychological warfare campaigns
against the American people much as if
they were trying to destabilize a
foreign country from the Russia Russia
Russia hoax
to the no collusion I don't think
prosecutors need to get involved in
destabilizing the U.S Trump trump did
enough of that 51 lying intelligence
offers how about them
they said it's Russia disinformation and
they knew it wasn't which made about
According to some of the great pollsters
that are right here made from anywhere
from a 10 to 17 point difference and yet
we still got more votes than any sitting
president in history in the second
election
we actually did much better in the
second election than we did in the first
election oh boy here we go the fake
dossier
paid for by the Democrats how about the
fake dossier okay so now he's going into
his normal routine Hello darling how are
you when they read about that
wasn't easy at all
spying on my campaign we caught them
spying on my campaign the FBI Twitter
files and so much more
it's all been a battle of disinformation
one thing after the other and all to
protect the radical left
Misfits
it's also no coincidence that these
charges against me came down the very
same day
evidence revealed Joe Biden took a five
million dollar bribe from Ukraine took a
five million dollar abroad it's a bit of
a stretch to say evidence revealed that
Mr Department don't even want to talk
about it
they showed something on television
tonight it had zero time on the three
major networks zero but my because it's
bogus Ted almost all the time I think I
had 351 minutes they had no minutes
okay
I think a lot of people are going to
vote yeah I think a lot of people
[Music]
I will tell you I just left Miami and
I've never seen love in the streets like
that I've never there were like a few
hundred people
I've never seen love like that because
they know they know what we all go
through they know what we've gone
through and they see it and they're
smart and you know many of those people
coming from Cuba Venezuela other
countries they've seen this happening to
their countries I used to say that
the United States if it keeps going this
way it's going to be Venezuela on
steroids and now we're buying oil from
Venezuela can you believe we have more
Liquid Gold under our feet than any
other Nation but we're buying tar
from Venezuela and we're refining here
in Houston the dirtiest worst oil
probably anywhere in the world
and we're refining it so you can imagine
what's going up in the air and all
beautiful stuff we're not taken out of
the ground and making a lot of money and
paying off debt and reducing taxes still
further which we were in the process of
doing
they want to distract from the real
Espionage and the real crime so let's
use president Trump to do so let's go
out and let's indict president Trump so
they don't talk about the five million
dollar bribe just yesterday Senator
Grassley revealed that the barisma
executive who allegedly paid the bribe
reportedly has crooked Joe
on tape they have 17 tapes I understand
that he must be a nice guy to deal with
right
the guy from barisma nice company
they got him and Hunter on 17 different
types supposedly but the FBI isn't
showing him
remember they impeached me for asking a
simple question about Biden's corrupt
dealings in Ukraine and now they see
that once again I was right I was right
I was totally right
this actually had some focus at the
beginning it's gone completely sideways
now totally protected Republicans all
you must finally get tough you've got to
get tough you got to get tough and you
got to show them
when you arrest your leading political
opponent we no longer have a democracy
when people are allowed to pour through
our open borders and our elections are
rigged our country is in very serious
trouble
when inflation is allowed to rage when
energy Independence and dominance it's
we had Independence and dominance we
were going to be soon very very dominant
within six months we're going to
dominate the whole world with energy
make a fortune we were going to be
paying off debt and lowering taxes at a
level that nobody's ever seen just
rambling now yeah this is it's this is
meaningless rambling in case anybody's
just turning this on taxes spiral upward
in an uncontrolled way
when murders are allowed to roam
murderers these are horrible Killers
murderers are allowed to roam the
streets of our democrat-run cities
unchecked by the way interesting report
today about the dramatic reduction in
crime in New York City which already has
a lower crime rate than Oklahoma City
rooms and they know their locations and
they're roaming our cities all over and
some of them are coming in right now
through our borders
but then you have a nation that as we
are is in serious serious decline we
have a nation in Syria state line
if the Communists get away with this
it won't stop with me they will not
hesitate to ramp up their persecution of
Christians pro-life activists parents
attending school board meetings and even
future Republican candidates which they
do
we must end it permanently and we must
end it immediately now that the seal
so important is broken the seal is
broken by what they've done they should
never have done this
this was an Unwritten rule you just
don't
unless it's really bad but you just
don't but the seal is now broken
in addition to closing the border and
removing all of the criminal elements
that have illegally invaded our country
make it America energy independent and
even dominant again and immediately
ending the war between Russia and
Ukraine I'll have it ended in 24 hours
don't know how but sure I will appoint a
real special prosecutor to go after the
most corrupt president of the history of
the United States of America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
name a special people are trying to
leave did you see that
and all others involved with the
destruction of our elections our borders
and our country itself they're
destroying our country
and when I'm re-elected and we will get
reelected we have no choice we're not
going to have a country anymore I will
totally obliterate the Deep State we
will obliterate go in conspiracies
and we know who they are I know exactly
who they are tell us
they want to take away my freedom
because I will never let them take away
your freedom it's very simple that's
what it is yeah they want to silence me
because I will never let them silence
you that makes you silence
and I am the only one that can save this
nation because you know they're not
coming after me they're coming after you
and they just happened they're coming
after Trump for the things he allegedly
did
on November 5th 2024 Justice will be
done we will take back our country and
we will make America great again thank
you God bless you all thank you thank
you very much great job thank you
there you go
all right I mean
[Music]
so Trump first arguing that he had the
absolute right to take everything he's
accused of taking seemingly
acknowledging he did it
then saying other people committed
crimes too and they haven't been charged
so a couple different arguments really
unbelievable
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
well there it is Trump lumbering off wow
what an incredible incredible speech as
all of you
uh clearly clearly noticed
well
what can we say what can we say more or
less what we expected not exactly what I
would call compelling legal arguments
made not exactly compelling legal
arguments is it where I think we will
leave it all right everybody thank you
for joining me it's been a long day
multiple streams I hope you check out
the podcast if you're new here make sure
you subscribe on YouTube make sure
you're following on Twitch we do this
stuff all the time uh and I really
appreciate everybody here meeting so
many of you people dropping in messages
and saying different things it's been uh
quite a day and much like Trump I am now
going to Lumber off if you will allow me
alright everybody we'll see you tomorrow
big big program much to prepare see you
then